[Musique]
on nettoyé vous qu'il y ait deux pas
plus cher une faute rococo beauté bien
sûr photo
ils manquent pas ta vie tu est
insupportable je veux plus te voir dans
ma cuisine
allez va t'en alors soit défendu tu m'as
déjà perdu 7 cloud et de tournevis mes
plus beaux rêves jouer ailleurs personne
n'en veut plus belles mois dans cette
notion si tu es tu es gentil on ne te
donnerais pas mais je suis gentil petit
moteur puisque c'est comme ça je pars
vous ne me reverrez plus jamais vous
serez très malheureux bien fait pour
vous une main il dit toujours ça et ils
s'arrangent toujours pour rester calmes
malgré tout on aime bien surtout quand
il se tient tranquille
ils vont pas très bien attrapés par
différents campus 80
[Musique]
oui mais pas ce que je veux faire
madonna
[Musique]
alors ma mais je trouve qu'on prend la
fuite
bah ce temps durs je comprends tout tu
as fait le malin tu a crié très fort que
tu voulais partir
et maintenant que tu voudrais bien
rentré je peux peut-être t d sera oui
montgaillard fois debout bon écoute bien
voilà ce que tu vas faire un tacle ou
papa part d'attaqués en va de vie que se
passe-t-il
vous êtes en danger pas possible
explique toi vite d'où je m'évanouis
genre décide de quitter la maison mais
je suis revenu pour vous sauver vraiment
sur la route j'ai entendu monsieur
bougon qui disait jean vazel chez les
papes a pu cette fois debout ainsi la
maison est toujours aussi intense au
regret je le losa la porte à porte aux
profs jeu ville dans mon atelier
merci pâte asus ne nous quitte plus
jamais oui merci papa victime ou son
chat en donnerait un gros gras tobacco
avait mis bon ordre dans la cuisine du
brésil chambre jamais finis à temps
vite vite moquez-vous bord arrivait en
atelier parce qu'heureusement attaque
loup vient chercher ça c'est à toi t'as
bu du thé en faire autant
[Musique]
chaque papier mat à zut à bien récité sa
leçon et je n'ai pas fini de rire
bravo félicitations tout est bien rangé
sauf
le coin de parachute bon il veut qu'au
pire à 100 fois je suis à vilain petit
désordonnée et bien croyez vous qu'il y
ait de pâte à pêcher il ne faut trop
époque
notez bien sur vos droits il me manque
[Musique]